[Music]
The Birth of a Nation so The Birth of a
Nation is directed by Nate Parker's
ultimately a first-time director he's
done a couple of shorts I believe this
is first feature-length film it also
stars Nate Parker as nat turner
all right so birth of a nation takes
place in the 1800s we're talking slavery
America not exactly the Golden Age of
American history or anything like that
so Matt Turner is versed in the Bible he
ministers to the slaves every Sunday and
the slaves are kind of getting restless
not only the fact because they're slaves
and miserable but there's a drought and
so some people have been like hey if you
feed the slaves less you can save on
food and cost so this whole propaganda
scenario happens where they're like hey
if Nat Turner ministers to the slaves in
the verses of the Bible that just say
hey mind your master I think all will be
okay he's seen enough in his life
where he's like you know what yeah
that let's just revolt but that
part doesn't happen until much later in
the movie all right first of all what I
liked about this movie is something I
see a lot in first-time directors they
have a lot of enthusiasm so they show
you a lot of neat stuff passion behind
the camera stuff you know a lot of
tracking shots a lot of panning shots it
looks beautiful than a very dark time in
the movie totally engrosses you that's
what I look for in period pieces you
know is whether or not I feel like I'm
actually in the time eze movie does pull
you right into the time however there
were these moments of visual metaphor
you know like sees the girl he loves
looking like an angel there's an ear of
corn that's bleeding they're woven into
the movie in a very jarring way and
you're like I don't know what I get why
they're trying to happen but it doesn't
work so don't have them and I respect
the fact that he showed the unapologetic
brutality of it we saw that in ten years
of slave also but ten years of slave
what gripped me and that one is the fact
that this guy was free and then one day
he wakes up it's like oh yeah you're a
slave now you've lost your life birth of
a nation I felt relied on the brutality
of slavery for the sake of showing
brutality of slavery to carry the movie
for a lot of it and that doesn't always
gel well as a form of cohesive
storytelling so show it but just don't
rely on it to carry a film all in all
the revolution of it the thing that Nat
Turner is known for happens in the last
third of the movie maybe forth and a lot
of the movie's leading up to that
conflict if it's not slow and boring
it's just brutal
something going hey this is what's
coming this is what's happening this is
why you're here this is why you have to
watch this you kind of feel as lost as
the movie probably is too and when the
conflict goes down it picks up your oh
we're in a revolution now no the
revolution doesn't last too long and
maybe that's why it's only a short part
of the movie about me training day
lasted one day that took two hours I
feel like if the conflict is here and
the build-up is here you get a shorten
the build-up widen the conflict showed
more and it wouldn't made the movie a
little more interesting the thing I do
like is the first guy at Turner kills it
actually he threw up because of it I
mean she literally physically made him
ill and I remember seeing that and be
like how many times how often do you see
someone who's never killed anyone before
kill somebody in a movie and he's like
alright now we're doing it on to the
next one I love the fact this movie took
a pause to show that the guy actually
physically got ill because he's just not
a killer
however it also just put it in my mind
that this movie is going to go places
and it's going to be a new experience
let's experience it however by the end
of this movie I don't feel it lived up
to that perception it's really
frustrating because this movie has a lot
of potential based on his premise right
there are a lot of Bible verses that
these slavers used to subdue the slaves
we like you see this is Scripture you
saw that in 12 years of slave fassbender
totally use that they use it in here too
however for every verse like that
there's another verse going none oh
don't treat people like that you're a
dick if you do paraphrasing and that's
mentioned in this movie this movie tells
you that is the motivation for him nat
turner doing this whole revolt however
it's not hit home because you don't feel
it at no point do you see this conflict
going down and you think to yourself
these two are fighting over like beliefs
in the same book that's a fascinating
thing to me and the movie never really
hit that point home and that just bums
me out and the movie is varied it's
black and white there's no middle ground
to it I just I don't mean you know what
I mean example army hammers in the movie
actually does a good job in here and you
kind of get the feeling that he in that
Turner are as civil as nice as it could
have been until it just one day falls
apart and then that's that I mean
there's this one scene where this dude
has a dog and it just gets on that
Turner's it's like my property and army
hammer comes barreling around the
corners like he's with me looked visibly
angry to a point where you're like oh
he's like protective of him and at a
point in the movie there is such a turn
between these two were you're like did
it was that building up did it
I didn't feel the build-up and that
really fell apart like today like now
and I'm not saying the movie was
illustrating that they were friends I'm
saying the movie was executed in a way
that kind of gave you that feeling and
if that wasn't supposed to be then that
is a flaw in the movie not a point in
that Turner's revolt you know that some
of these houses have children in them
and you don't know what like are they
did the kids die I think the adults got
wiped out so I I don't know the movie
leaves me with that question in my head
so I'm left to be like okay you guys
leading a revolt you've had it you're
good you're just going to kill the
people who have been brutalizing you all
this time or you sociopaths who are also
killing children I don't know guys in
the end the birth of a nation is
interesting historically speaking but
really doesn't stand out as much more
than full another movie that takes place
in the slave era in the end you're
watching historical stuff happen and
then the Revolution and then it ends and
then you walk out going yep totally
gonna be shown in high school this movie
should have been more interesting than
it was it wasn't and would probably be a
better time if you're drunk yeah can't
really say it's a party the being bad
taste wouldn't it all right guys so The
Birth of a Nation have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's the
hardest historical movie for you to
watch you know the movie you watch
you're like yeah I watched it it's rough
so I'm not gonna watch it again whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]